- What have I come to terms with?
Wow.
(clears throat)
The possibility, I've never been married,
the possibility that I
never will find somebody.
It's been developing over years
because I took care of my mom,
sorry, before she passed,
and it was 14 years.
She had dementia.
And I never knew she'd
survive that long.
Or I didn't know, and
yeah, how that would go
when I decided to become her caregiver.
So, I think it was during that time
that I relegated myself to the possibility
that I may not find somebody.
And so many years went by
and she passed in December.
It's now August.
So, many years have gone
by that now I think,
okay, well, am I gonna be alone?
Or, maybe I'll find
somebody, I don't know.
- Probably that I'll never be happy.
(bystander laughing)
Don't laugh.
- [Bystander] I'm so with you on that.
- I think I'm just always,
every day, you wake up
and you go about your day.
But the constant, what's
gonna make me happy?
What's gonna make me happy?
And even if I do things, I travel,
I have my kids,
I have everything I want,
but I still feel unhappy.
And you have a partner like my husband,
he's always telling me,
"You're not gonna be happy.
"Why are you doing this?
"Why do you want that?
"You're still not gonna be happy".
And then you get the new kitchen,
or you get the new plastic
surgery, you get the boobs,
and a month later,
you're still walking around
with your face made up
because I'm still unhappy,
But I have everything.
I'm not sick.
I don't have any ailments.
My family's happy.
We're comfortable, but why am I unhappy?
Why do I want?
Why can't?
What I want, I think, is unattainable.
And I think that somehow,
I have to learn to
create my own happiness.
- [Thoraya] What's something
you've finally come to terms with?
- Racism.
One time when me try to go to Tijuana,
the border patrol told me jump the hill.
It's immigration patrol.
I feel really bad,
because I can't believe living,
one line divide Mexico with US
and it's a lot of racism.
For me, after 15 years living here,
I feel comfort because every day is just,
every day you see the racism.
Every day is different people.
I work in the casino.
I have with the Chinese people,
African people, a lot of people
diverse in other countries.
In my job I see the
racism, my coworkers too.
- [Thoraya] So, your coworkers are diverse
and you all feel racism
towards you?
- Yeah.
After how many years
I'm here, I feel good.
- [Thoraya] It doesn't
bother you anymore?
- It doesn't
bother me anymore.
- [Thoraya] So, that's what you mean
by you'd finally come to terms with it?
- Yeah.
- I don't know if this
is gonna make sense but,
I came out of a cult, so I
guess I just came out of terms
that even if you lose loved ones
because of something that you believe,
like strongly believe,
and that it's not good for you,
or safe for you, it's okay.
It was just literally my mom,
my sisters, my brothers
people that, I grew up with.
And it was hard on me,
but I came to terms with it already.
My kids were born and raised in there,
but I gave them the choice.
I never had the choice.
I was forced into it and I left at 40,
I'm 45 and I feel that I'm
barely learning how to live.
Yeah.
- I've come to terms
that I'm an alcoholic.
I went to a meeting this
morning, an AA meeting
and I spilled out my heart
in front of all these guys.
And,
I don't,
I'm not 100% convinced that I'm alcoholic.
I don't think I ever will be,
but I'm closer to that reality
than I was yesterday.
And,
I'm at peace with that, you know?
it's a peace that I
can't put my finger on.
It's something sublime.
- Something I finally come to terms with
is probably just looks,
face, body, everything.
I guess accepting that it's gonna change.
I'm gonna get skinnier and bigger,
and I'm gonna get older
and my hair's gonna get frizzier
maybe deader, stuff like that.
And I guess I finally
come to terms with that.
None of that really matters at all.
I have a lot of scars
and big pores and things,
that are never gonna change,
but that doesn't affect anything at all.
So, I guess I finally come
to terms with that I'm more.
That I'm more than what I look like.
My soul is what's really
roaming this earth.
- Probably that not
everybody's gonna like me.
Yeah.
- [Thoraya] And what made you
come to terms with that?
- School.
I don't have friends, but it's fine.
I have family and stuff
like that and my boyfriend,
so that's good.
But yeah.
- [Thoraya] What's something
you've finally come to terms with?
- Losing my vision.
I had a stroke and the blood
clot went behind my eye
instead of to my brain.
So, maybe I'm lucky, but I lost vision.
Acceptance is always something
that makes you feel better.
And it turned out to be okay.
Everything's fine.
- Nothing.
I'm still in denial.
Yup.
I don't like thinking about stuff.
It'll take care of its own in the future.
I don't know.
I don't like to think about the future.
It makes me very anxious.
Thinking of failure for
me is just like a no go.
I'm always positive.
I always try to stay positive,
so I haven't come to terms with anything.
It'll always work out eventually.
(people chattering indistinctly)
- Yeah, you know what?
In a personal matter,
a very personal matter,
I have a 20 year old
daughter that's in school
and I thought we were very,
very, very close to each other
and she went away to college.
And I never hear from her.
I just never do.
I've come to terms with that,
realizing that I'm a father
and daughters and sons like
me when I was 20 years old,
I would go to my mother.
I would never talk to my father,
like I would talk to my mother.
And so it's just part of,
I think it might be part of human nature,
or part of the family dynamic,
but it took me a while to,
like I had to ask a lot
of people about that,
in order to come to terms with it.
- That I lie to myself a lot.
Yeah, I pretend that I do certain things
because I like to do them,
but actually it's just because my friends,
or like the group that surrounds me,
consider them that they are right.
But I think sometimes they're not.
So, it's more like just to fit, you know?
Yeah.
- I think recently I've
come to terms with the fact
that I am shy and more antisocial
and introverted.
And that I don't need to
always put myself out there
and put myself in more
uncomfortable situations,
just to fit in and be more extroverted.
- Okay, I recently just
went through a breakup,
like a few days ago.
I'm shaking.
(speaker laughs)
It's okay to let people go.
To let yourself find
happiness and to grow,
you gotta let people go.
Yeah.
That's the best it's gonna get.
(speaker laughs)
- I'm 56 years old now
and I realized suddenly like last year,
that my very good friends
are not very good friends.
I thought I would never accepted it.
I was so angry.
I was losing all my, it's like a tree.
You are losing your feet, or your branch.
I don't know.
But now that I realize
and that I accepted it,
honestly, I feel so good
but to wait 50, at 56 to do
that, I think it's a shame.
I should have done it before.
This is it.
- I think the finality of life.
That you can't have life
without it having an end.
And at this age, I'm about to turn 88
and I think I've come to terms pretty much
with the finality of life and its ending.
I'm not so crazy about
the process of ending
'cause it's not too comfortable,
but I'm happy with life
and I'm okay with its end.
- I've finally come to terms with the fact
that I'm not always right
and I often have to stop and think,
is this one of those moments?
I have already raised my daughter,
and started over by
adopting two little ones.
So, I kinda got a second
chance to not be right.
It feels good.
- Okay, I think something
that I have come to terms with finally,
is that very few people in this world
truly care about you.
I think that we go
through life growing up,
being assisted in a lot of things
and we mistake that for
people actually caring,
about what we have to say,
or about just us in general.
But then when you become an adult,
I think you realize that
that's not really the case.
It was all just to help you get here.
And now that you, I don't know,
now that you're fully grown
you realize, well I think
you got your parents
if you're lucky and you got your siblings,
also if you're lucky.
Beyond that, if you have
more people than that,
who like truly do care about you,
like I said you can consider
yourself very lucky.
Coming to terms with that wasn't easy,
but yeah, I find it to be true.
- [Thoraya] I want you to reverse that.
Do you feel that from your side too?
Do you think, do you only
care about your siblings,
or your parents and very few friends?
- Yes.
I think people are centric.
I wouldn't describe humans as selfish.
I would describe them as centric,
in that your needs come first
and then once your needs are met,
then you start thinking about the needs
of people who are close to you.
And then beyond that,
I think your capacity
to care about strangers,
is much more limited than
we'd all like to believe.
- Hi everyone.
Thank you for watching.
I'll be posting bonus footage
from this episode on my Patreon.
That means more answers and
extended cuts of each answer.
If you wanna see it, you can sign up.
I'll have it linked in my description
and if I ever do follow-ups
on the people you see in this episode,
that'll be on my Patreon as well.
Thank you guys for watching.
I love you all and I'll see you next time.
(gentle music)